here with reaction Texas Senator Ted
Cruz uh Senator uh thanks for being with
us
now
I am not a Harvard Law School graduate
like you are but I think there is a
great distinction between I never spoke
to my son about his farm business
dealings and now that we have all the
evidence available to prove to the
contrary that in fact he did now they've
changed it to well he never went into
business with his son I would say that
is a huge difference and not even you
couldn't even describe it as parsing
words here
yeah look I I gotta say Sean I I want to
play poker with Kareem Jean-Pierre
because she is a terrible terrible liar
and and she's got to tell you you know
sometimes in a poker table someone will
twist a ring or they'll pull their ear
or they'll do something when they're
bluffing Kareem Jean-Pierre her tell is
she'll tell you I'm going to tell you
the exact same thing I've told you a
thousand times before you know the next
words out of her mouth are going to be
totally different from anything she's
ever said before you know so yeah well
let me get your reaction to what
happened in court today and and I don't
know if you share my suspicion there's
no way in my mind that the prosecutor
and the defense did not have a firm
agreement that there would be no future
charges and I think the Judge called
them out and then they they knew that
they couldn't admit it publicly that's
what I think do you agree with that
suspicion and so I do I think they had a
deal this was a sweetheart deal this was
designed to give Hunter Biden a slap on
the just let him get away with zero jail
time and its most important function was
to cover up for the big guy to cover up
from Joe Biden to say all these matters
are done it's all closed it's over I
think if this plea hearing had been the
day after the plea deal was announced I
think it probably they would have stuck
to their guns and it might well have
been approved but what happened is
several weeks passed and the several
weeks passed more and more evidence came
out the fd-1023 from the FBI came out
the two IRS whistleblowers testified
before the House of Representatives
accusing the Attorney General Merrick
Garland of lying under oath accusing the
Attorney General of obstruction of
justice in this case and suddenly the
Delaware U.S attorney's Office in the
court realized they couldn't stand up in
court and say oh no we're not going to
investigate any of this new evidence
that's all come roaring out that became
impossible to say so they said well yeah
of course we're going to investigate
that and suddenly Hunter's lawyers said
we're out of here and the whole thing
blew up I'm glad it blew up this deal
stunk from day one and it was about
covering up Hunter and more importantly
covering up Joe Biden's involvement in
the corruption Senator based on what we
know now we have Joe Biden on tape
admitting that he leveraged 1 billion
taxpayer dollars to get got a prosecutor
in Ukraine fired the prosecutor had been
investigating barisma that was paying
his son Hunter a massive amount of money
even though the sum went on Good Morning
America admitted he had no experience at
all based on what we read with the
WhatsApp messages I'm sitting here with
my father and then well lo and behold a
Chinese oil exec sends over five million
dollars to the bidens within a week
do how would you describe it I would say
these are this is the Biden
uh bribery
Scandal allegations uh and if you're a
prosecuting attorney uh how strong a
case are you looking at what by what we
know right now
so we have now the fd-1023 I have it in
my hand it's the FBI report that was
prepared in 2020 when a confidential
human Source raised allegations that Joe
Biden as vice president personally
received bribes five million dollars
personally himself his son five million
dollars from a Ukrainian oligarch in
exchange for official favors when he was
vice president of the United States this
fd-1023 is damning I do a podcast three
days a week verdict with Ted Cruz the
podcast has gone into the details of
what's in this d1023 walking through it
the specifics where among other things
you know some of the quotes from it so
that the confidential human source told
zlotzewski that due to shock and shock
it is the Ukrainian Prosecutor's
investigation into barisma that it would
have a substantial negative effect on
barista's perspective IPO in the United
States and zlotzewski the Ukrainian
oligarch replied something to the effect
of don't worry Hunter will take care of
all of those issues through his dad
zocheski also allegedly said it cost
five million to pay one Biden and five
million to pay another Biden sloczewsky
further allegedly said Hunter Biden
quote was stupid and sloczewsky's dog
was smarter this is in the FBI form
the confidential human Source asked did
Hunter Biden or did Joe Biden tell
zlichewsky he needed to retain Hunter
Biden's lochewski replied they both did
and zlichewski says he has many text
messages and recordings that could show
he was forced to make such payments he
said he has 17 audio recordings of his
conversations with the bidens 15 with
102 with Joe this stuff is damning stuff
if this is true
Joe Biden should be impeached and
impeached not for high crimes and
misdemeanors but for bribery which is
explicitly enumerated in the
Constitution he should be removed from
office he should be prosecuted he should
go to jail for taking millions of
dollars of bribes if this is true well
uh all evidence is showing for following
the money they got the five million
dollars after the WhatsApp message uh
and and certainly after Joe leveraged
our money in Ukraine and got the
prosecutor fired zero experienced Hunter
got paid an obscene amount of money uh
and that continued anyway Senator Cruz
great to see you thank you for being
with us sir hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else